[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle agriculture alimentation
écologique mais aussi politique et cette
semaine nous recevons Philippe Vigier
bonjour bonjour et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour Philippe
d'Eure-et-Loir depuis 15 ans mais
docteur en pharmacie et biologiste de
profession à l'Assemblée votre premier
mandat vous l'exercer en 2007 après
avoir soutenu François Bayrou vous
suivez donc Nicolas Sarkozy est devenu
un député c'était l'époque des majorités
absolues un vieux souvenir alors vous
êtes également conseillé régional du
Centre Val de Loire vous avez été maire
de Cloyes-sur-le-Loir pendant 16 ans vos
mentors sont avant tout votre père
Jean-Louis qui a été mère conseillé
général et régional et puis l'ancien
ministre Jacques barreau la Haute-Loire
donc la Drôme où vous êtes né mais c'est
en Auvergne que vous puissiez vos
racines et ce tempérament volcanique qui
vous caractérise c'est donc aussi en
Auvergne que vous vous emmener pour le
menu du jour n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre
oui avec des lentilles aux petits salés
ou quand on regarde l'assiette plutôt du
petit salé aux lentilles et en dessert
une banane flambée au cognac dans le
dessous des plats la morille le
champignon préférée des Français se
cultivent sous serre en France une
pratique importée de Chine reportage
dans cette émission dans les pieds dans
plat une équation impossible comment
sauver la pêche française sans vider les
océans pêcheurs et écolo n'ont pas les
mêmes réponses
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
alors Philippe Vigier que dit de vous ce
petit salé j'ai tourné ça dans tous les
sens certes c'est un plat traditionnel
qui peut vous ressembler mais il n'est
pas vraiment une spécialité de votre
Drôme natale ni de votre heure et Loire
d'adoption quant aux lentilles je ne
vois nul trace dans votre CV
d'implantation au puits qui aurait pu
vous convertir à ce caviar du pauvre non
en fait la passerelle est plus politique
que gourmande et oui ce petit salé qui
vous poursuit il raisonnait déjà dans
vos propos qui ne manquaient pas de sel
sur Elisabeth borne et son 49-3 lorsque
vous avez déclaré que c'était un coup
porté à la démocratie vous l'Allier du
MoDem voilà que vous avez donc déversé
du sel sur une plaie ouverte celle des
retraites histoire donc de bien rentrer
dans le lard ou le jarret du
gouvernement ce sel là contrairement à
la saumure qui permet de garder les
aliments n'est pas certain de vous aider
à conserver de bonnes relations avec
Renaissance bref à l'issue de cette
crise politique vous êtes forcément
taraudé par le doute Philippe Vigier sur
cette majorité mais sachez que le doute
et le sel de l'esprit donc déguster sans
modération votre petit salé adoré
la description d'abord il y a beaucoup
de choses je suis néandro mais je ne
suis pas dromadaire et oui on dit cela
parce que mes parents habitaient à
Privas et je suis attaché à l'Auvergne
ce sont mes racines familiales j'ai
grandi et je passais des années
merveilleuses je suis arrivé à l'âge de
5 ans pour être précis sur le parti à 21
ans pour faire mon internat à Paris et
ce petit salon lentilles c'est dans des
plats préférés de ma grand-mère qui
était merveilleuse cuisinière et mon
grand-père était bouché or les lentilles
d'Auvergne fait que Puy-en-Velay c'est à
40 km de mobylac Natal qui s'appelle
lauchillac et le petit donc vous avez
bien une implantation d'Auvergne ah mais
c'est pas une application
les lentilles du Puy-en-Velay sont la
Bible
c'est d'Auvergne mais le petit salé
voilà non mais non le petit salé avec
autre chose se fait un peu partout
mais c'est un des plats traditionnels
traditionnel de même que le pot-au-feu
qu'on déjeuner on en avait ça le samedi
chez mes parents à Clerm différents ou
j'ai grandi oui d'ailleurs fait une très
grande partie de des mascularité donc
c'est le dernier en France quoi c'est
vraiment la petite madeleine
ine oui c'est non mais c'est mon enfant
c'est logique grandi c'est là que j'ai
passé toutes mes vacances d'été et c'est
là où quelque part je suis venu à dos
aussi ou je me suis a donné à la pêche
parce que je suis pêcheur je suis depuis
chasseur mais ça c'est depuis quelques
années j'adore les randonnée et puis
j'aime les routes sinueuses et puis j'ai
une passion c'est le sport automobile et
c'est d'ailleurs on devient que j'ai
démarré et alors ce plat donc c'est
votre grand-mère qui le qu'il faisait
c'est ça elle a laissé une recette que
vous avez gardé cette particulière
naturellement qui était un peu secrète
elle nous faisait deux plats souvent le
dimanche c'était le petit salon aux
lentilles et puis il y avait ce qu'on
appelle un Jacques alors un Jacques
c'est une tarte aux pommes c'est une
tarte aux pommes mais avec
sur la partie supérieure recouverte il
fallait pas que la pâte par une autre
pâte absolument il fallait pas on a deux
rues au café on mettait la petite
cheminée absolument pour qu'elle puisse
respirer et comme cela elle se décoller
mais pas beaucoup et on avait pas le
droit d'entrer dans la cuisine à partir
de 7h du matin sinon la pâte produit
froid et ma grand-mère nous est
attention la pâte doit rester à la bonne
température alors goûter ça vous
rappellera vos premiers et moi
d'adolescents en Auvergne vous allez
nous dire si je suis pas sûr que ce soit
aussi bon que la recette de votre
grand-mère mais vous allez nous dire
quand même
il est très bon alors les lentilles
parce que c'est
c'est à peu près les souvenirs que vous
avez conservé au niveau de saveurs
oui mais il y a les restaurants qui tous
les jours vous savez le soir un soir
c'est la choucroute le lendemain c'est
la blanquette
4e jour ça peut être je sais pas encore
un pot-au-feu que sais-je encore alors
choisir la viande c'est la clé du succès
c'est pas très original un bon mélange
de morceaux de porc plus ou moins gras
avec ou sans eau alors là on a juste du
jarret on le voit avec hausse mais on
peut aussi avoir de la poitrine la
palette les Chine des travers de porc on
peut même rajouter des saucisses fumées
ou Strasbourg etc ou Montbéliard 2
l'idéal c'est de saler sa viande
soi-même c'est de faire le petit salé
mais ça c'est un peu compliqué parce que
ça nécessite pas mal de choses donc vous
pouvez gagner du temps en zappant cette
étape prenez le temps quand même si vous
achetez déjà de la viande salée bien la
dessaler au moins deux heures dans un
grand saladier d'eau froide ce qui est
conseillé pour les grosses pièces pour
la cuisson ne désossez jamais votre
viande vous le voyez la laisser c'est ce
qui va donner le goût exactement
Brigitte ça donne plus de saveurs et
faites la cuire soit l'eau soit au
court-bouillon lentement à petit
frémissement et en fin de cuisson vous
égoutez la viande vous la coupez en
morceaux et c'est là que vous la
mélanger aux lentilles que vous avez
fait cuire préalablement je sais pas si
votre grand-mère faisait comme ça
absolument mais elle rajoute quelque
chose qui n'est pas vue là c'est un
petit morceau d'oignon ah oui mariné au
fond de la poêle et qu'elle avait des
lentilles avec les lentilles et après
elle mettait son petit salé et qu'elle
devient c'est que comme vous l'avez très
bien dit il faut qu'il cuise
naturellement dans le gras pour qu'il
puisse avoir le goût qui puisse extraire
et puis elle mettait un petit peu
d'herbe et elle adoré faire cela et
votre grand-mère elle faisait la saumure
elle faisait elle empilait cette viande
avec du sel pour la conserver absolument
comment on conserver à l'époque comme
ils étaient bouchés c'est comme ça on
conservait tout cela dans la saumure
faire cela oui là vous allez moi je suis
d'accord avec Brigitte vous allez faire
hurler les puristes parce que moi je
m'attendais à une recette super
sophistiquée monsieur Vigier colle c'est
c'est au micro-ondes
dans les œufs brouillés on met de la
crème mais vraiment la crème elle vient
parce que c'est les œufs qui vont et
vous mettez quoi alors juste des œufs
vous les battez dans un peu de beurre
comme a dit mais ça dure 40 minutes hein
et c'est les œufs qui vont faire cet
aspect un peu crémeux la recette du
puriste vous avez raison c'est la vôtre
c'est la recette un peu rapide parce que
bon mais oui il faut le vendre comme ça
extraordinaires et franchement brouillés
à l'extérieur naturellement d'accord et
puis j'adore faire du petit filet mignon
qui doit être osé qui doit surtout pas
être cuit entouré de petits champignons
parce que j'ai également j'adore aller
chercher les champignons et parce que
c'est pas sûr et parce que d'abord c'est
très relaxant d'être dans la nature
c'est formidable c'est l'évasion on va
parler des champignons et puis j'aime
bien tout ce qui concerne le barbecue je
je vois pas beaucoup de spécialités de
la Drôme et de l'Ardèche la caillette
vous savez faire non spécialité de la
Drôme la Drôme c'est un accident de
parcours c'est pas de matières
il y a quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup
ça vous surprendra pas si la crème du
marron avec de la crème
fraîcheur ça c'est exprès de chez
Clément faut gilet naturellement je suis
d'accord avec la marque par excellence
et puis j'aime bien évidemment les
marrons que l'on peut faire alors auprès
de la chambre de cheminée dans ma ferme
et donc il m'arrive de temps en temps de
faire revenir ses marrons alors je crois
que Lady Go c'est aussi un plat que vous
aimez particulièrement parce que
l'aligot ça c'est et l'aligot ce qui est
exceptionnel si un jour vous allez dans
les bureaux auvergnat notamment
cantaloupe département du Cantal donc de
la purée vous savez d'ailleurs pas très
loin d'ici du côté de la gare
Montparnasse on tombe dans une très au
plan du Cantal de très bonne aligots
donc vous prenez la tombe alors en
fonction plus ou moins jeune et ensuite
il a fait revenir naturellement dans la
purée écrasée
le temps de la faire pour bien Insérer
puis après après la grande recette c'est
lorsque vous avez le plat dans les quais
il y a l'aligot on le coupe on le rendu
bien et après on le coupe et on vous le
serre comme cela et il tombe directement
dans l'assiette il y avait qu'un ciseau
on coupe le fil de l'aligot et alors
vous mettez de l'ail un peu d'ail en
principe dans l'aligot un tout petit peu
d'ail ça dépend je demande toujours à
ceux qui viennent à la maison si oui ou
non ils veulent parce que certains
n'aiment pas manger je vous sens très
traditionnel on n'a pas entendu parler
de riz cantonais de nems de de curry
indien vous avez aussi la queue vous
ouvrir aux autres expériences et aux
autres pays à toutes les autres
expériences c'est vrai que j'ai été
marqué quand vous avez la chance d'avoir
une grand-mère qui a été extraordinaire
bonne cuisinière une maman qui était
très bonne cuisinière également quelque
part ça vous influence et franchement
une saucisse de Morteau c'est excellent
j'adore prendre une très belle
andouillette et pas très loin d'ici
également il y en a des magnifiques mais
un poisson me ravi mille fois donc c'est
vous qui cuisinez à la maison
qui arrive samedi soir j'ai un petit
poisson que je vais préparer pour la
famille qui
est qu'avec des herbes juste un peu de
beurre
un petit peu de citron et puis je mets
ça au four à peu près 45 minutes et puis
après je vais faire les petits légumes
autour souvent j'aime bien travailler
les vieux légumes parce que c'est super
agréable en ce moment l'hiver en plus
les vieux légumes d'hiver c'est super ou
alors parce que j'adore aussi c'est
toutes les types de fondue vous voyez
parce qu'on peut faire des fondus au
fromage de garde comme on peut faire du
fond du homofort jeune de preuve bien
sûr quand on est en Savoie tous ces
plats là parce que je trouve qu'ils
inspirent une véritable convivialité un
peu comme ce studio et c'est ça parce
que moi le moment du repas c'est un
moment que j'aime pour une raison
particulière vous avez rappelé Brigitte
dans mon cursus que que fait mon interne
à Paris et j'ai eu la chance d'y passer
l'hôpital Saint-Louis à l'hôpital Necker
dans les hôpitaux lorsque vous êtes
interne on dit de garde donc on
travaille quelquefois 24 heures 36 ans
seul moment de détente des compressions
de d'échanges et lorsqu'on vient se
mettre à tâche c'est pour ça que vous
n'avez pas et ces fameuses bananes
flambées et je me suis un très bien qui
m'a fait tant aimé des bananes flambées
on en parlera plus tard mais je vous
expliquerai pourquoi parce que c'est des
moments où on échange on a le temps de
parler on attend de se poser et c'est
aussi comme ça que la vie politique me
passionne parce que un de mes rêves
c'est d'avoir plus de temps pour le
dimanche soir et avec mes copains à toi
de la table pour discuter et du coup à
Paris vous faites comment pour vous
restaurer vous allez à la buvette là de
l'Assemblée ou vous commandez ou comment
je suis un adepte de la buvette le mardi
matin à 8h je crois que tout est un des
deux ou trois premiers pensionnaires
entre guillemets pour prendre un café et
mes tartines voilà j'ai mes pirit j'aime
bien déjeuner rapidement et le soir vous
faites un petit frichti tout seul dans
votre arranger
pas de finitions parce qu'on est à Paris
on est beaucoup à l'Assemblée donc la
buvette
et puis voilà c'est le moment de mes
collègues une collègue est-ce qu'on peut
passer un moment ensemble tu en entend
un petit resto naturellement dehors il y
a quelques belles adresses pas loin
d'ici mais je sais que vous faisiez
assez attention à votre ligne est-ce que
c'est vrai et est-ce que c'est difficile
quand on est député justement de pas
grossir parce qu'on a souvent des repas
je fais attention à maline que vous avez
rappelé que j'étais volcanique ça me
permet d'évacuer beaucoup d'énergie donc
vous avez pas trop de problèmes
à faire à peu près 5 km par jour à pied
sur une semaine
j'ai la chance d'habitude pas très loin
d'ici un petit peu de vélo de temps en
temps ça permet aussi de conserver la
forme non mais je fais attention quand
même évidemment alors on va parler du
vin parce qu'avec ce petit salé aux
lentilles vous nous avez demandé un
Pessac-Léognan un des vins que vous
affectionnez particulièrement on est
évidemment dans la région de Bordeaux
AOC AOP sur ce Pessac Léognan c'est dans
le vignoble des Graves
c'est juste au sud de Bordeaux en fait
Pessac-Léognan il y a 80% de rouge 20%
de blanc là on est sur un millésime 2019
et donc on a 40% de Merlot et 60% de
cabernet sauvignon mais c'est que
l'oignon on peut aussi trouver du
Cabernet Franc et puis c'est un élevage
en cuve et en fût de chêne et le nez est
assez riche en fruits rouges vous allez
nous dire si
c'est ce que vous retrouvez vous
effectivement des un peu cerise je
retrouve parfaitement c'est mon vin de
Bordeaux préféré c'est pas un Margot
c'est pas un Saint-Estèphe mais j'aime
beaucoup le pixacle oignons qui a une
véritable structure qu'une longueur en
bouche qui n'est pas agressif et qui est
très boisé et je trouve qu'en plus c'est
un vin qui passe pratiquement surtout le
plat de viande de façon assez formidable
voilà
je vais vous rappeler un souvenir
pourquoi
vous avez rappelé que des pharmaciens
biologiques de formation donc je suis
allé faire le service des santé des
armées à Libourne pendant 6 semaines et
le soir à 17h30 on était libérés donc là
on a repenté un peu les vignobles
connaître et on a découvert avec
quelques copains supplément voilà et
depuis j'ai de l'épaisé
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
c'est le quiz
alors Philippe Vigier on l'a vu avec le
petit salé le sel est un ingrédient
indispensable à la cuisine c'est pas
votre grand-mère qui vient le contraire
aussi bien pour conserver des aliments
que pour donner du goût sauriez-vous
nous dire si ces affirmations concernant
le sel sont vrai ou fausses a le sel
d'Ey cette île américaine est réputée
pour sa couleur grise vrai ou faux
vrai non il y a un petit piège c'est sa
couleur noire c'est du c'est du sel un
peu volcanique justement un peu comme
Monsieur Vigier le volcan rouge
l'Antiquité encore un piège attention
dans l'Antiquité Aristote désigne le sel
comme une substance divine vrai ou faux
je connais les poussées d'Aristote mais
alors
le sel d'Aristote
allez non faux
comme substance
la ville de Salzbourg en Autriche doit
son nom à ses mines de sel vrai ou faux
faut potasse non vrai Salses sel et
bourg village Salzbourg à Salzbourg
et on fait alors là les besoins humains
en sels par jour vrai ou faux
non non trois quarts de grammes
donc on mange beaucoup trop salé et
c'est pas très bon pour la santé alors
voilà vous allez peut-être pouvoir vous
rattraper deuxième quiz vous le Drôme
moi alors pas vraiment vous aimez
forcément les ravioles de Royan oui
seriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sur les ravioles son vrai
ou fausse ah dans la farce on y trouve
du Saint-Marcellin vrai ou faux vrai
elles sont vendues par plaquettes de 54
non 48 donc c'est bon c'est l'instrument
pour découper la pâte se nomme une
ridelle
vrai dès l'autre nom de la raviole et
l'oreille d'ours
tic-tac
c'est pas un nom qui est on m'a dit que
c'était le deuxième nom de la raviole
très bon les ravioles délicieux ouais
mais ça c'est la Drôme oui
vous avez un CV trompeur né dans la
Drôme et en fait c'est un problème de
maternité qu'on n'avait pas imaginé et
on parle tout va bien alors vous savez
qu'en France le repas occupe une assez
large place et particulièrement en
politique c'est souvent là que ce nous
les deals politiques et que se fait la
petite et la grande histoire c'est la
brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé Philippe Vigier
de réfléchir à une anecdote pourquoi pas
politique autour d'un repas est-ce que
vous en avez une à nous raconter oui ne
vous raconter les dates de bonne dizaine
d'années c'est un peu un dimanche soir
et on avait organisé avec des copains un
repas des élus du constructeurs que
maintenant les conseillers
départementaux il y en a un qui je sais
qu'il aimait particulièrement bien
manger un soufflé au fromage
il y avait quelques morceaux de gésiers
dedans
en plus et on dit mon rendez-vous à 20h
prendre l'apéro et après naturellement
on partagera ce soufflet et le problème
c'est qu'un qui est arrivé à 21h30 donc
on a dû attendre 28h30 de prêter le
soufflet qui était complètement retombé
à partir de la pâte s'étend au collège
c'était absolument
bouffable j'ai envie de vous le dire
très librement donc en catastrophe j'ai
réussi à leur faire une belle omelette
voilà c'est pas les débrouiller tout à
l'heure
vous pensez à moi avec ma petite recette
rapide
dans la poêle ou vous la faites au
micro-ondes dans la poêle vous mettez
quoi dedans alors
un peu de muscade
et c'est très bon
je pense que plein de parlementaires ou
des lieux locaux ont connu ça c'est
parce que vous savez les dimanches on a
un très nombreux et de repas avec les
aînés les anciens et les communes aiment
bien habiter le député qui vient dire
bonjour qui dit que vous avez beaucoup
de communes dans votre sensation et moi
je mets un point d'honneur à aller là où
on m'invite et puis d'abord je vais vous
dire quelque chose quand je vais sur le
terrain ça me ressource je reprends de
l'énergie avec eux qui me permet ensuite
la semaine d'être là et de faire en
sorte d'être le plus possible au service
de mon pays et de leur territoire et en
fait l'ancien repas à midi traditionnel
apéro donc je fais une première commune
j'arrive on prend l'apéritif la deuxième
c'était le plat principal parce qu'il
était déjà une heure moins le quart 1h50
et donc là je me souviens très très bien
c'était une blanquette de veau
donc on me dit vous allez en prendre un
petit peu il reste un quart d'heure 20
minutes je fais encore 10 km je suis
notre commune et on me ressais une
blanquette de veau
c'est encore une troisième banquette de
veau donc là
on disait du HAC Chirac il était capable
de manger cinq repas par jour donc en
fait il faut être un peu organisé de
quoi vous mangez un petit bout de viande
voilà je dis bonjour à tout le monde je
vais voir tout le monde je vous dis
c'est que ces personnes dans ces cas-là
il faut que ces personnes qui vous
preniez rien vous l'avez vexez pas
prendre un verre de vin à chaque repas
non c'est pas possible vous pouvez pas
conduire je suis vraiment très
accompagné mais pour autant j'ai fait
attention de tremper les lèvres je pose
le verre technique pas dans les plantes
vertes
et donc vous avez eu un repas complet en
trois fois
même un repas le dimanche soir comme ça
ça permet souvent de zapper le repas de
faire attention à la ligne
[Musique]
dit la découverte de la morille le
champignon préféré des Français et c'est
le dessous des plats
donc cette saison vient de démarrer elle
s'annonce prolifique mais dépêchez-vous
car elle est courte sachez quand même
que la plupart des morilles ne vient pas
des sous-bois la France est enfin mise à
la culture de ce champignon mystérieux
toxique à haute dose et qui excite les
grands chefs c'est un reportage en
Normandie de Maïté fremon et de
Pierre-Yves de hœningue je vérifie que
toutes les alvéoles de la tête de la
morille au bout soit tout ouverte donc
là celle là par exemple qui est ouvert
jusqu'en haut elle est à maturité on
peut la ramasser de la morille partout à
faire tourner la tête des cueilleurs
amateurs ce matin-là florentin ramasse
ce précieux champignon mais ne vous y
trompez pas la cueillette ne se fait pas
dans une forêt mais sous cette serre à
quelques mètres de l'enclos de ses
vaches
on a cinq sauces en production mais
celle-ci la plus précoce donc c'est la
première qu'on ramasse et l'objectif des
tunnels c'est de d'essayer de recréer
l'ambiance sous bois
avec un passage d'air quand même faut
pas avoir l'effet cloche faut qu'il y
ait un mouvement d'air pour qu'il y ait
pas de développement d'autres
champignons et c'est seulement ça une
gestion de l'hygrométrie du de la mise
en terre de michelium à la récolte et le
par
I est éleveur de Boves après deux ans de
test après la plantation de la semence à
l'automne place à la récolte de la
morille une période courte de quelques
semaines début avril l'odeur libérée la
texture l'aspect tout type
quand on vient de les ramasser elles ont
pas beaucoup d'odeurs il faut attendre
une heure une heure et demie deux heures
et elles vont commencer à dès que le
comment ça sécher un peu l'odeur arrive
celle-ci c'est vraiment la taille idéale
on va être entre 20 et 25 g par Maury
donc c'est ce que les restaurateurs
demandent le plus chaque semaine les
restaurateurs de la région lui
commandent un à 6 kg de morilles qu'ils
vont 100 euros le kilo la saison
s'annonce plutôt bonne florentin pense
vendre les trois quarts de sa production
le reste partira au séchage comme lui en
France ils sont une centaine de
producteurs à cultiver la mort
cette cagette partira à une trentaine de
kilomètres de la ferme
[Musique]
alors les petites morilles normandes
voilà les bébés
Adrien Chauvin travaille la carte de son
restaurant à la demande du client
inscrite dans les entrées un client sur
deux la consonne
la morille de Florentin de l'ultra local
un grand OUI pour ce chef
de la France ou dans l'Est voilà c'est
ça vient de chez nous les morilles mis à
part aller 5% qui viennent de la forêt
et le reste c'est que des c'est que de
la production aussi bien les Chinoises
les Turcs il y a rien qui vient de la
forêt
avec notre farce film de volaille et
avec des ours
[Musique]
cuite dans un jus de bouillon là je vais
plonger mes morilles et là
tout tout petit du champignon
enfin le dressage
[Musique]
à la dégustation
c'est délicat
fin
le bluetooth
à cette crème de ciboulette
il y a plein d'arômes qui se
très très bon l'entrée leur coûtera 26
euros les Français sont prêts à y mettre
le prix ils sont aujourd'hui les plus
gros consommateurs de morilles dans le
monde
avant de parler de la culture de ces
morilles parce que c'est intéressant on
se reportage vous l'amateur de
champignons l'Auvergnat vous allez
parfois traquer les morilles dans les
sous-bois dans la campagne vous avez non
parce que comme vous savez j'habite en
Eure-et-Loir il y a quasiment pas de
morilles moi je traque le cèpe le trac
la girolle
les petits gris et je vous assure qu'on
fait quelques belles fricassées vous
avez jamais essayé la morille parce
qu'il paraît que c'est compliqué il faut
de la patience de l'entêtement ou de la
patience ou de l'entêtement faut trouver
les structures du sol qui vont bien et
la composition du sol qui va bien et en
Auvergne il y a des endroits que que je
ne connais pas mais je sais qu'ils sont
plutôt bien pour ni en Maurice chaque
année en fonction de la saison ça dépend
de vous savez que au mois d'avril la
morille elle se développe entre 0 donc
et 800 mètres 900 mètres d'altitude au
mois de mai il faut monter jusqu'à 1500
mètres 1600 mètres absolument et au mois
de juin c'est plus compliqué donc en
fait
parce que vous avez des études qui
peuvent vous aider
de la botanique et puis surtout
dès qu'on a un champignon dans les mains
ils sont connaît pas et bien à ce
moment-là on va voir celui qui connaît
ce qu'on peut mourir avec des amis de
phaloïdes et donc faut être extrêmement
prudent il y a quelque chose par exemple
qu'il faut fuir absolument quand vous
voyez un champignon que les champignons
ça pas bien exactement différencier
parfois un peu abîmé
c'est la plus simple
pour que
le chapeau rouge avec des petits points
blancs
de la tenue du champignon la queue du
champignon et celle-ci elle est
caractéristiques mais par exemple il y a
un champignon qui lui ressemble mais
Québec s'appelle la coulemelle qui est
délicieux et donc le mec qui pousse qui
est assez haute quelquefois et qu'on
ramasse on peut faire la confusion mais
voilà quand on sait pas on ramasse pas
et en tout cas moi je me donne à ce
moment favori le dimanche mais c'est le
dimanche vers lorsque manifestation se
termine vers 17h à 17h15 j'ai encore une
heure 1h15 où je peux aller dans les
boîtes tout près de chez moi
d'accord il voulait vous voulez découper
délicatement à la racine ça se coupe
très délicatement un champignon c'est ce
couple à la base comme ça
je suis pas comme ça on l'arrache pas
comme ça on prend son panier on le pose
délicatement parce que sinon il se
naturellement sera abîmé et vous savez
les préparer après parce qu'en fait
c'est difficile il faut pas trop laver
les champignons
[Musique]
une petite brosse on avait naturellement
ça peut être très sympa brosse à dents
sinon il y a des petites brosse douce
qui fonctionne très bien on passe un
tout petit peu sur l'eau si jamais il y
a quelque chose qui n'est pas déconné
qui est sale la terre non on enlève la
terre mais on l'a pas avec Clément la
frite avec la fameuse petite brosse et
ensuite vous les faites revenir à feu
très doux dans une poêle mettez un petit
chapeau par dessus et il relargue de
l'eau il a ça prend beaucoup de temps
une bonne fricassée ça peut prendre une
heure et quart 1h30 ça n'a plus de
poivre et on fait revenir au bout d'un
moment c'est absolument délicieux et dès
qu'ils ont vous le goûter et vous
trempez votre vous pointez votre couteau
à la verticale dans le champignon et
voyez que la chair est encore ferme
[Musique]
préféré des Français c'est vous aussi
votre champignon préféré je l'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup la morille comme la
trompette de la mort et noir qui est
très jolie qui ressemble un peu à une
girolle qui est jaune qu'est-ce que il a
tout ça c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle la
trompette c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
tomber de la mort absolument d'octobre
novembre et mais franchement la Maurice
et l'aristocratie du champignon comme
c'est cher
entre guillemets naturels il y en a de
moins en moindre c'est pour ça qu'on
vient de voir ce qui se passait en
Normandie
donc la plupart viennent de Chine Vienne
d'Inde de Bulgarie on les apporte
d'Europe centrale n'importe de Chine
mais vous saviez qu'en France on
commençait j'ai un peu découvert je
pense pas absolument
sur les champignons vous savez de façon
que le fameux champignon de Paris
parce que vous parlez de la Haute-Loire
vous voyez vous avez
magnifique championnat et surtout vous
avez des conserver de champignons
lorsque vous montez dans ce qu'on
appelle le massif du Gévaudan là où il y
avait la bête du Gévaudan chacun connaît
c'est un village qui s'appelle SOG et
SOGS c'est un village qui est à 30 km du
Puy-en-Velay et là vous avez des
conserveries et franchement vous avez
des bois merveilleux dans lesquelles
vous trouvez les champignons à profusion
je pense que j'ai envie de dire alors on
peut les laisser sécher aussi on peut
dessécher donc là vous les couper
du goût quand même quand elle est séchée
de la réhydrater à partir de là le
relargue le goût mais je vous dis à très
sincèrement un champignon séché n'a pas
le goût d'un champion traditionnel frais
que que vous allez cueillir à 17h et à
20h surtout dans votre assiette alors
moi je ferai un distinguo parce que
peut-être que la morille de Turquie ou
Chine et pas bonne qualité mais moi je
préfère une morille séchée qui a bien
effectivement trempé avec son jus plutôt
qu'une morille fraîche de mauvaise
qualité qui ne sent rien celle-ci dans
le du reportage à mon avis a été m'a dit
qu'elle était très bonne
mais
ils sont gorgés d'eau alors que la
véritable
jour de Turquie aucun goût mais c'est à
l'image vous savez de tous les produits
congelés prenez par exemple un lecteur
d'Auvergne naturellement frais c'est
merveilleux et si vous congelez bien
formidable il y a une maison
exceptionnelle si vous le congelez bien
franchement vous le redécongelez et je
vous assure qu'après je vais décoller
c'est un peu comme le dégustation de 20
aveugle franchement même les grands
connaissances du mal à savoir
parfaitement si oui ou non un salecteur
se congèle très bien un Cantal c'est
plus difficile ou une forme d'ambiance
et vous saviez qu'elle était toxique là
la morille absolument
ça peut être très dangereux pour pour
l'organisme alors la morille on l'a dit
c'est un produit qui est
particulièrement cher on va s'intéresser
là à des produits du quotidien avec
notre panier LCP
alors dans politique à table on
s'intéresse effectivement à l'inflation
alimentaire en cette période
d'augmentation des prix alors dans ce
panier nous avons des produits du
quotidien du beurre de la farine des
pâtes du chocolat des œufs ou encore du
jambon et c'était laine Bonduelle qui va
comme ça régulièrement relevé les prix
constatés dans un supermarché de la
région parisienne alors en 6 mois son
panier a pris 7%, une hausse globale qui
masque quand même des hausses bien plus
importantes vous allez le voir parce que
les trois plus forte hausse d'abord la
première ce sont les pattes avec des
coquillettes à plus
27%, les œufs à égalité avec le jus
d'orange là on se trouve à plus 24% et
puis les céréales plus
21%. donc pâtes céréales la farine aussi
qui a beaucoup augmenté il y a un lien
avec avec l'Ukraine inévitablement avec
l'augmentation du blé des céréales
vous avez raison ce panier d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on m'interroge à l'heure actuelle
il y avait une grande tension dans le
pays avec la référence sur les retraites
rapidement tout à l'heure que j'avais
déclaré lorsque le fameux 49-3 était
déclenché moi les gens me parlent les
habitants de la circonscription mais pas
du du moyen il me disent oui voilà ça
devient de plus en plus cher on va faire
des choix d'ailleurs un reportage cette
semaine expliquez bien que
certains changent leurs habitudes ceux
qui consommaient du Nutella avec la
marque classique prennent une marque
comme on dit distributeur et c'est vrai
que ça sous une vraie question et on le
voit mais les boulangers dont je suis
assez proche de ma circonscription me
dit oui l'énergie a tellement évolué est
tellement augmenté que je suis obligé
d'augmenter ma baguette devant ou 30
centimes alors ce que montre aussi les
études c'est qu'on met tout sur le dos
de l'Ukraine mais que finalement
certains en profitent aussi pour
augmenter les prix et se servir un peu
au passage
il en profite pas pour augmenter le prix
parce que lui le produit qui lui est
livré il a augmenté donc en fait ou
alors il a large ici la plus de marge il
est obligé de fermer le rideau c'est
vrai qu'il y a des spéculations sur
l'énergie on voit bien ce qui s'est
passé
qui ont gagné un argent fou d'ailleurs
il est allé chercher il faut savoir que
quand on redistribue comme une décision
dans l'hémicycle ici du maître un
bouclier et tarifaire pour le gaz pour
l'énergie enfin bref tout cela s'est
pris sur des super profits sont faits
par les entreprises donc évidemment il y
a des super profiteurs dans ces cas-là
il y a un effet
c'est toutes les discussions proches de
mon territoire et en particulier les
agriculteurs c'est comment on invente
ces circuits courts sans que les
intermédiaires à chaque fois répercutent
des hausses qui ne sont pas toujours
justifiées et vous vous êtes pour une
taxe sur les super profits j'en peux le
mettre le président du groupe modem le
dividendes je pense que ceux qui
ont des super dividendes sur une donnée
particulière donc par exemple d'abord
peut-être préciser ce que c'est qu'un
super dividende il est normal qu'une
entreprise gagne de l'argent il est
normal qu'elle fasse de la profitabilité
il est normal qu'il y a des dividendes
sur le réinvestis donc ça c'est vertueux
après ce qui est anormal c'est que tout
d'un coup il y a une augmentation folle
de ses dividendes et que tout aille il y
a quelques actionnaires qu'on nous donne
rien aux salariés ou qu'on répercute
tout sur le consommateur et c'est là où
jean-paulmatique vous faire œuvre de
justice sociale de justice fiscale il
est pas normal que
la richesse dans l'entreprise
qui était en train de passer ça n'ira
pas véritablement aux salariés en fait
ça ira dans les caisses de l'État ça ne
revient pas
il fait quoi l'état il a c'est lui qui a
mis le fameux bouclier énergie et
plafonnant à 10% l'augmentation du coût
pour que tous les Françaises et tous les
Français il y a combien d'entre qui
chaque semaine nous interpelle en disant
mais voilà moi je suis pas dans le
Bouclier moi j'ai plus de 10 salariés
moi j'ai un contrat où mon énergie va
être multipliée par 4 cela qu'est-ce
qu'on leur répond j'en ai plein en tête
qui m'interpelle qui me connaissent
Philippe aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire et il y a pas une
semaine où j'ai pas 5 6 7 8 alertes sur
ces questions là vous faites remonter
ces cas après
[Musique]
j'ai fait remonter naturellement à Bercy
en expliquant qu'il faut trouver des
solutions on a mis beaucoup de choses en
place la France a été celle qui d'abord
avec la covid on a tout oublié mais moi
j'ai pas oublié c'est 150 milliards
qu'on a mis sur la table ce qui se passe
avec l'Ukraine c'est pour ça que
vraiment dans un pays dans lequel je
crois que l'amortisseur sociale est là
même si même si il faut être attentif à
ceux qui n'y arrivent plus et pour cela
au travers de la politique de salariale
dividende de la participation moi je
crois il faut amener les gens dans une
histoire il faut que quand il se donne à
fond pour un métier mais il faut qu'il
récompense il y a pas de récompense ça
ne marche pas
alors on vous l'avait dit tout à l'heure
vous l'avez esquissé vous êtes fan de
pêche alors on va s'intéresser à la
réglementation européenne sur les aires
marines la réduction des zones de pêche
aurait des conséquences considérables
pour la filière alors on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
et oui les pêcheurs sont en colère
l'extension des airs marines protégées
décidées par la Commission européenne
les inquiète il craignent de voir à
terme leurs zones de pêche restreinte
sans compter les restrictions dues à la
mort de nombreux dauphins les
conséquences financières pourraient
lourdement impacter la filière Hélène
Bonduelle et mashallah et Philippe Le
Crau
[Musique]
c'était fin mars dont les ports normands
et bretons comme ici à Brest une
opération filière morte aucun bateau ne
rentre aucun ne sort les pêcheurs
protestent contre le nouveau plan pêche
de la Commission européenne on est
devenu des parieurs on est devenu une
profession à abattre
l'Europe envisage d'étendre les aires
marines protégées en les faisant passer
de 12 à 30% d'ici 2030 et voudrait
progressivement et supprimer les
chalutage de fonds tolé chez les
pêcheurs qui craignent de ne plus
pouvoir ramasser certains coquilles
c'était quasiment plus de
50-5% de la flotte de pêche artisanale
qui aurait été condamnée c'était tout ce
qui touche le fond or par exemple quand
vous pêchez la coquille vous utilisez
une drague qui touche le fond quand vous
faites de la production d'huîtres plâtre
par exemple en bec Quiberon vous touchez
le fond et donc cette proposition a
heureux pourrait fait d'interdire toutes
ces pêches là en réalité ce n'est qu'une
recommandation l'Europe ne fixe pour le
moment aucune nouvelle contrainte de
pêche
la France compte plus de 33% d'air
marine protégées sur son littoral avec
différents niveaux d'engagement
certaines associations environnementales
dénoncent le manque d'ambition
européenne pour la protection des fonds
marins la Commission européenne a fait
un rappel à l'ordre mais il n'y avait
rien de contraignant malheureusement la
France est le premier espace maritime
européen donc si nous on n'est pas
capable de vraiment protéger nos aires
marines protégées ça envoie un signal
pathétique au niveau non seulement
européen mais international alors
comment allier survie d'une profession
et protection de la nature dans le golf
de Gascogne c'est une autre décision qui
inquiète les pêcheurs la fermeture de
certaines zones pour protéger les
dauphins
des cétacés retrouvés de plus en plus
souvent échoué sur les plages ou
attraper accidentellement dans les
filets d'échaluts
un mois en été ça représente en moyenne
sur les navires 50% du chiffre de perte
de chiffre d'affaires une société qui
perd 50% de son chiffre d'affaires elle
coule selon certaines associations de
protection des océans il y aurait dix
mille dauphins tués chaque année sur la
côte atlantique
alors Philippe j'ai est-ce que la
Commission européenne a raison de
vouloir étendre ses airs marines
protégées l'objectif c'est de passer de
10 à 30% en 2030 c'est de la folie c'est
trop bien
active Natura 2000 qui va s'appliquer à
partir 2024 où on veut réduire donc de
30 % en particulier les endroits où il y
a plus de poissons ce sont les alors
on peut continuer à pêcher en fait
les protéger les surproje oui il a
protégé sur protéger qu'on protège
l'environnement bien sûr qu'on fasse
attention aux zones sensibles j'ai porté
sur le territoire de matières
conscription des zones de protection
spéciale d'oiseaux donc je peux
comprendre tout ça ce qui est
inacceptable c'est la brutalité avec
laquelle s'applique les pêcheurs ne sont
plusieurs phases de premier sujet le
brexit
c'est que maintenant les Anglais ils ont
pris leurs billes donc en clair on a les
péchés quelquefois et dans les eaux
britanniques on ne peut plus y aller
deuxièmement on parlait du coup
d'énergie ils le prennent plein de face
troisièmement imaginez qu'on met de
l'argent avec la Commission européenne
pour leur dire les bateaux on les coule
on sort les bateaux de la flotte on a 50
bateaux qui sont sortis de la flotte à
l'heure actuelle rendez compte on leur
donne de l'argent pour détruire leur
outil de travail
c'est des activités là aussi
traditionnelles tu vends très artisanal
avec des petits patrons pêcheurs quand
deux trois salariés il y a 5000 emplois
qui sont concernés moi j'entends bien la
protection de l'environnement
environnement
[Musique]
on prélève trop ou pas non parce qu'ils
ont mis il y a des quotas les cotations
respectées et on a mis des plantes
prélèvement en place et les plantes
prélèvement ils font que il n'y a pas de
diminution contrairement à ce qui
racontait il n'y a pas de diminution
justement de cette faune et ce qui
permet donc de continuer d'avoir des
poissons parce que eux-mêmes pour leur
plan de régulation faut pas imaginer
comme ça qui découvre tout d'un coup que
il faut protéger les espèces ou qui nous
prend plus à les pêcher donc là vraiment
je vous le dis avec eux bon je suis pas
du tout je connais mal ces territoires
pas parce que c'est pas mentir et toi où
j'ai grandi ou j'habite mais je suis
très sensible à ces questions là oui
environnement vous voyez on est en train
de faire une zone de protection de 130
hectares tout près de chez moi oui mais
pour autant la cohabitation des
activités économiques et la protection
de l'environnement c'est pas un diktat
on dit se terminer il y a plus
d'activité économique je suis pas
d'accord avec vous des diktat de
brutalité il n'a pas vraiment eu de la
brutalité les pêcheurs ont un peu crier
avant d'avoir mal parce que
effectivement l'Europe a dit on va faire
interdiction de pêche aux chalut et de
fonds et finalement c'est au pays de
décider la France ne va pas le faire
donc il y a pas vraiment brutalité au
contraire il y a les écolos de dénoncent
même un certain laxisme quand ça
commence à Bruxelles en général mais
pour l'instant moi j'ai été étonné même
là
il est récurrent depuis
Brigitte l'a dit un moment il ira plus
il y aura plus de poissons
c'est savoir s'il y a plus il y a pas il
y a encore et ils le disent eux-mêmes
ils le font vérifier eux-mêmes ils sont
pas fous ils vont pas aller trop
prélevés pour derrière ne plus avoir ce
qui leur peine risquez de tous les jours
quand je dis un dictat oui parce que
quelque part il faut bien comprendre ça
c'est un peu comme sur le glyphosate moi
je suis très attentif devant mon métier
à la protection sanitaire à la
protection de l'environnement à la bonne
santé pour tous mais je peux pas
accepter qu'à un endroit la France
prenne en pleine face alors que nous
sommes je vous rappelle nous sommes le
pays de monde qui a la deuxième façade
maritime mondiale deuxième tasse
maritime mondiale parce que il y a pas
que la France métropolitaine il y a tous
les outre-mer or la pêche c'est un
revenu absolument considéré
dans le temps oui puis il faut le faire
en concertation avec eux il faut des
systèmes de sortie qu'ils soient
acceptable tolérable parce que là j'en
viens à le dire il y a rien de
contraignant véritablement aujourd'hui
vous savez ce qui n'est pas contredit
aujourd'hui il va le venir demain
d'ailleurs le secrétaire d'État avait
Berville l'a dit je crois très fortement
si on applique les règles telles que
elles sont prévues par la commission
pour 2024 c'est la mort de la pêche moi
je ne veux pas accepter écouter je peux
pas avoir un ministère de l'Agriculture
de souveraineté alimentaire je peux pas
parler de souveraineté industrielle de
souveraineté alimentaire de souveraineté
tout court énergétique on vient de
parler de l'Ukraine et donner les moyens
oui à la préservation de l'environnement
mais dans l'intelligence non à la
prévention de l'environnement dans le
dogmatisme que direz-vous pardon que
direz-vous à vos enfants quand les
océans sont morts c'est pas moi qui pose
la question c'est Hugo Clément qui la
poser au ministre et moi je la reprends
et je vous la pose à vous d'abord vous
savez quand moi j'ai grandi on m'a dit
un jour il y aura plus de pétrole il y
aura plus de ressources il y a plus rien
on s'est aperçoit qu'elle a toujours
2emement qu'il faille prendre soin de
l'environnement la réponse est 1000 fois
oui et devant vous un député avant même
qu'on voit-il loi sur l'énergie
renouvelables camion place avec son
préfet de département une commission
départementale d'énergie renouvelable et
voyez je veux même faire une confidence
j'ai monté un Living Lab les villages
c'est un espace de respiration de
discussion où on met autour de la table
des hommes et des femmes attachés à
l'environnement des promoteurs
industriels des élus pour qu'on discute
ensemble comment on appréhende le
développement d'énergie renouvelable sur
un territoire on a des éoliennes chez
moi on a du méthaniseur on est des
photosvoltaïques en à Stéphane Bern qui
permet de te poser à toutes les
éoliennes on a trouvé par la discussion
un compromis je n'accepte pas le disque
je veux trouver des solutions ce qu'on
appelle de passage j'ai réussi à faire
de protection spéciale des oiseaux avec
les agriculteurs avec les chasseurs avec
les élus c'est qu'il faut pas décision
qui arrive d'en haut de Bruxelles et qui
impose comme ça au pêcheurs il faut
discuter en France on n'aime pas
l'Europe parce qu'elle fait ça on n'aime
pas la France parce qu'elle fait ça
faisons confiance au territoire après
qu'il faille des axes qui faille des
directions qui failli c'est un peu ce
que vous allez dire à l'instant bien sûr
que la protection de l'environnement
dira nos enfants nos petits-enfants et
j'ai des petits enfants et je leur dis
on va aussi s'occuper de vous quand je
vois la fonte des glaciers c'est un
sujet mais le combat doit être général
on peut pas être uniquement la France un
nouveau confrère ce matin parler des
efforts qui ont été faits par la France
sur les émanations de gaz à effet de
serre c'est très bien mais on est loin
derrière certains pays surtout très en
avance sur d'autres regardez la Chine
regardez les États-Unis quand on prend
le chalutage de fond par exemple on voit
bien il y a des études qui montrent que
ça abîme effectivement les fonds marins
est-ce que là vous dites bon il faut
changer les pratiques quand même il faut
évoluer là-dessus oui mais vous pouvez
pas le faire contre la profession il
faut
il y a un sujet qui est un sujet majeur
et en fait ça vaut pour tout ce que je
vais vous dire
regardez il y a quelques jours une
convention citoyenne a beaucoup
travaillé sur la fin de vie
et je pense que là on va avoir et je
fais partie du comité d'évaluation de la
loi Leonetti avec Olivier falordu je
pense qu'il y a l'intelligence et les
plus importantes lorsque vous avez des
citoyens vous avez des retours de la
table vous si vous disiez au pêcheur
est-ce qu'on est déjà d'accord sur le
constat est-ce que ou non il y a moins
de poissons
ils le sont oui mais après ce qu'il faut
c'est les associés à des décisions qui
permettent de donner des perspectives en
vie aussi d'exercer leur métier mais ce
qui n'est pas tant de leur dire que ce
métier ne peut plus exister tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui de préparer à la
disparition progressive de chalutiers
affrontement et on bouge pas vraiment je
vous dis que votre métier demain il
existe plus qu'il y aura plus que le net
et vous allez me dire mais attendez le
contact que l'on doit sur un plateau ça
n'arrête pas la même chose donc je pense
qu'il faut essayer peut-être préparer
plutôt que de se retrouver à prendre des
mesures drastiques
que les décisions de 23 de la Commission
européenne elle s'applique début 2024 il
faut trouver le temps de la
compréhension pour moi qui suis même qui
choisit i le mot volcanique qui est
plutôt réactif je pars du principe que
lorsqu'on est capable d'écrire à
plusieurs mains à peu le problème des
retraites vous voyez vous pouvez pas
laisser d'un côté syndical gouvernement
vous êtes obligé à un moment ou un autre
c'est l'ancien syndicaliste qui vous dit
ça vous vous dites il faut une médiation
oui
donc il faut se parler allez on va
continuer à se parler et on va passer au
dessert c'est le péché mignon
alors voici venu le temps du sucré
Brigitte avec une banane flambée pour
avoir la banane recette originaire de
Louisiane elle aurait été inventée en
1951 par un certain paul-blangé qui à
l'époque officiel comme chef au
restaurant Brennan dans le quartier
français de la Nouvelle-Orléans à
l'origine bien sûr elle était arrosée de
Rome vous vous y apportez non pas la
french ou l'auvergnatoutch mais la
French Touch avec le cognac alors
pourquoi le cognac sur cette banane
flambée plutôt que de rester aux
origines de la recette un souvenir
formidable
1982 l'hôpital Saint-Louis mes premières
bananes flambées l'hôpital Saint-Louis
quand vous êtes interne il faut bien
manger un peu comme vous voilà nous
sommes à table et bien lorsque vous êtes
vous travaillez toute la journée vous
avez quand même trois quart d'heure une
heure pour manger à midi une trois quart
d'heure une heure pour manger le soir et
une fois sur dur nous élever pas cher
vous coupez la banane en deux et on
avait la chance
vous étiez capable d'assurer les
urgences derrière sans problème
vous êtes très dessert ou vous êtes
plutôt salé vous
je suis plutôt salé
petit salé
et sinon quand c'est desserts alors
c'est quoi c'est crumble j'aime bien et
puis mon dessert favori je veux dire ce
que c'est la banane flambée moi c'est
deux desserts
à l'hôpital le soir voilà et c'était des
bons moments de discussion voilà et j'ai
un deuxième dessert que j'adore que je
viens qui vient encore de ma grand-mère
et de ma maman ce sont les yeux au lait
voilà
c'est absolument formidable mais alors
comment on fait les parce qu'on en
trouve jamais dans les cartes des
restaurants moi j'ai jamais
un savoir-faire faut pas que ça trouve
faire alors ça ressemble à quoi en fait
le c'est un dessert
caramel sans caramel si c'est la crème
caramel mais pas la crème caramel comme
on peut voir pas la buvette qui est une
sorte de clan caramel forme de flan
caramélisées
c'est souvent servi qu'un tout petit peu
tiède avec la crème ma grand-mère une
crème à la vanille d'ailleurs il y a des
petits morceaux de vanille qui était
tout autour c'était absolument sucré et
là vous ne savez pas refaire la recette
ça reste vraiment souvenir d'enfance
alors goûter cette banane flambée c'est
pas pour critiquer chez Françoise parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire des miracles
mais quand même genre comme elle n'a pas
été flambée à l'instant je pense que
vous n'allez pas reconnaître votre
banane de l'hôpital quoi que l'hôpital
je ne sais pas
elle est très bonne idée
quand même du mal à nous servir comme ça
un peu froid et voilà merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LCP